so I'm Bernie Sanders the real Bernie
Sanders feel the burn the burn feel the
burn I do like the sound of president
Sanders I want to hear our name more in
the media you spice up his campaign I
think it would help Bernie if you learn
to juggle I'd even feeling teach him
this land was made but you and me this
land is your land this land is my land
from the California to the New York I
personally the Affordable Care Act
allowed me to switch insurance which I
wouldn't have been able to do otherwise
and get the kind of treatment I need
it's the right move to improve upon what
we've got the Muslim nations they're
going to have to get their hands dirty
their boots on the ground I think the
idea of using us ground forces is a last
resort is the right approach
I do not have a super PAC he's doing
justice to the Bernie Sanders name by
running a clean campaign we have got to
have the best educated workforce in the
entire world giving people equal access
to education makes a lot of sense tax on
Wall Street I don't really I don't know
I do like him I think he stands for
social responsibility in a way that's
that's very refreshing in America ago
surprised to say all Bernie Sanders are
good guys